gracias
y yo os voy a llevar en un paseo por la
montaña mañana el sábado imaginaros que
esta noche dejáis la ciudad y os vais a
pasar unos días en la montaña
mañana por la mañana os despertaes con
estas vistas esa sensación de
reconectarse con la naturaleza respirar
el aire puro disfrutar del paisaje bueno
hemos pasado unos días maravillosos en
la montaña jugando con los niños
paseando leyendo pero porque todo lo
bueno siempre se acaba y llega el
momento de regresar a la ciudad
cuando llegamos a la ciudad
siempre nos da esa sensación de shock de
la vuelta a la realidad de la polución
el estrés del día a día los pisos sin
pagadores y a muchos de nosotros se nos
queda esa idea romántica de que un día
así me iré a vivir para siempre en el
campo porque ahí es donde me siento bien
de verdad
pero bueno mientras no hemos tenido
todavía el valor de cambiar radicalmente
nuestro estilo de vida regresamos a
nuestras casas nuestra casa es nuestro
pequeño oasis en la ciudad aquí es donde
uno se siente bien donde todos nos
sentimos protegidos de estas agresiones
del exterior y es donde por fin podemos
volver a respirar tan profundamente como
en esos días tan buenos que hemos pasado
en la montaña
o es que no es bien así
según el banco mundial de datos el 50
por ciento de la población mundial vive
en ciudades de estas personas que
vivimos en ciudades pasamos hasta el 90%
del tiempo en interiores ya sea en casa
en el colegio en la oficina y además el
aire interior llega a niveles de
contaminación casi hasta 5 veces
superior que en el exterior
y esto cómo es posible bueno es cierto
que fuera hay coches y polución y todo
esto pero también hay una ventilación
constante por acción del viento
entonces el aire atrapado el aire
contaminado que entra aquí dentro se
queda atrapado dentro
bueno ahora que todos sabemos estos
datos a lo mejor no sea mala idea
salirnos todos fuera ir a respirar un
poquito de aire pero bueno creo que no
es muy operativa ahora mover a 300
personas entonces un poco la pregunta
que se nos coloca es como hemos llegado
hasta aquí y para ello os voy a contar
la historia abreviada de los materiales
de construcción y del aire que
respiramos en nuestras casas pues
empecemos por la prehistoria en la
prehistoria no existía el concepto de
materiales de construcción los
cavernícolas lo que hacían era
simplemente habitar las cuevas que
encontraban
luego cuando pasamos a la edad antigua
es cuando por primera vez en la historia
se habla de construcción lo que hacía el
hombre de esta época era recoger los
materiales que encontraba a su alrededor
como la piedra la madera y construir sus
casas ahora pasamos a la edad media y al
periodo romano aquí es cuando por
primera vez se mezclan diferentes
materiales naturales para conseguir un
material nuevo como por ejemplo el
hormigón que no es más que una mezcla
arenas de piedra y de agua y que nos
permite hacer un material nuevo entonces
si estos nuevos materiales desprendían
algún tipo de sustancias que es lo que
representamos con estas bolitas aquí
está en realidad no era un problema
porque el aire interior y el aire
exterior era básicamente lo mismo los
edificios ventilaban de manera
permanente
ahora hacemos un salto en la historia y
llegamos a la revolución industrial con
la revolución industrial la capacidad de
producir en serie se han inventado un
sinfín de materiales de construcción
nuevos de nuevas materias primas
muchos de estos materiales nuevos con
prestaciones que hasta entonces no
existían como la flexibilidad o la
transparencia por ejemplo y aquí es
donde la cosa se pone interesante pues
muchos de estos materiales tan
fantásticos con nuevas prestaciones en
realidad desprenden unas sustancias que
no se ven y no se sienten pero que son
muy perjudiciales a nuestra salud os
pongo un ejemplo sabeis ese olor a coche
nuevo eso que uno se siente tan a gusto
y tan orgulloso de su coche nuevo que
invita a sus amigos a sentarse dentro ya
disfrutar de mí una máquina nueva pues
malísimo
en realidad ese olor son compuestos
orgánicos volátiles que son unas
sustancias que se desprenden de los
paneles del interior del coste del coche
de los plásticos y que afectan muchísimo
a nuestra salud tienen efectos
neurotóxicos son disruptores endócrinos
y pueden incluso llegar a ser
cancerígenos
pero volviendo a lo que pasa en nuestras
casas no olvide contaros un momento muy
importante de la historia en los años 70
ocurre el embargo del petróleo y junto
con el embargo del petróleo una nueva
preocupación el ahorro energético
entonces para evitar posibles pérdidas
de energía es decir de frío o de calor a
partir de esta época los edificios se
diseñan para ser lo más hermético
posible entonces qué pasa el aire
contaminado que se genera que sale de
estos materiales y que se genera dentro
de nuestras casas se queda atrapado
dentro y es por ello que se habla por
primera vez en la historia en la
problema en la problemática de la
calidad del aire interior
y bueno y a día de hoy donde estamos hay
muchísimos materiales de construcción la
tecnología el conocimiento no paran de
evolucionar incluso hemos llegado a un
momento en que ya existen materiales que
tienen propiedades activas de
descontaminar el aire o de matar
bacterias que lo representamos con estos
puntos verdes
pero sin embargo la problemática de la
calidad del aire interior se mantiene
entonces como podéis ver no todos son
malas noticias y todo esto que os he
contado ahora mismo se puede resumir de
una manera muy simple pues tras un
proceso de tres años de investigación
entre otras cosas obviamente nos hemos
dado cuenta de una cosa muy sencilla que
es que todos los materiales de
construcción del planeta se pueden
agrupar en tres cajas
están los materiales inertes es decir
que no desprenden nada ni absorben nada
como por ejemplo la cerámica o casi
todas las piedras
tenemos la caja número 2 que son los
materiales que desprenden cosas que son
estas sustancias que no se ven y no se
sienten pero que afectan al aire que
respiramos como por ejemplo algunas
pinturas pavimentos de pvc incluso con
algunas maderas esto también pasa
y esta la caja número 3 que son los
materiales que absorben cosas absorben
cosas y las transforman en otras vale
los materiales de la caja número 3 se
dividen en dos grupos están los héroes y
están los villanos entonces los héroes
son aquellos materiales que captan estas
sustancias del aire o las bacterias que
llevamos en nuestras manos y las
transforman en algo inerte en algo
inocuo como son por ejemplo materiales
fotocatalíticos o el cobre que es un
material naturalmente bactericida es
decir que mata las bacterias
del otro lado están los villanos
entonces los villanos son materiales que
está mal también captan estas sustancias
pero que las transforman en algo todavía
peor
como por ejemplo sabéis esas maquetas
antiguas de las casas de nuestras
abuelas pues imaginaros a un niño
jugando en una de estas maquetas y este
niño estornuda los mocos que se le
caigan a la moqueta que al final no son
más que bacterias se quedarán ahí
acumulados y bueno y el efecto
multiplicador no hace falta explicarlo
pero el mundo de la construcción
actualmente no va por aquí a día de hoy
los materiales de construcción se eligen
con base a tres factores sus
prestaciones es decir este material me
sirve o no para lo que quiero el coste y
la estética lo que nos hemos dado cuenta
es que aquí nos falta un factor muy
importante que es el factor salud
como muchos procesos o casi todos los
procesos de investigación el nuestro
empezó con una pregunta que era podemos
desde la arquitectura ayudar al proceso
de cura de un paciente
bueno me encantaría poder decir que la
arquitectura cura pero no es así sin
curas son los médicos pero lo que sí
podemos hacer desde la arquitectura es a
través de una elección cuidada de
materiales de construcción garantizar
una calidad ambiental óptima y con esto
facilitar el proceso de cuerda de un
paciente y no perjudicarle obviamente
pues el resultado de esta ecuación es mi
trabajo y se llama friend y martínez
lo que hacemos es yo entiendo estas
variables que me dan información sobre
cómo los materiales se afectan al aire
que respiramos como sus emisiones de
compuestos orgánicos volátiles si son
tóxicos en caso de incendio o su
composición química por ejemplo si bien
tiene estas variables y las puedo
ponderar pues puedo puntuar
materiales de construcción de 0 a 100
y os pongo un ejemplo que seguramente os
resultará familiar algunos de vosotros
cuántos de vosotros sois padres o madres
la mitad más o menos de los que sois
padres o madres seguramente muchos de
vosotros habéis vivido el momento de
decorar la habitación del primer hijo y
elegir el color de sus paredes verdad
azul si es niño rosa si es niña fijaros
que en ningún momento vuestra decisión
se basa en si esta pintura puede afectar
a la salud de nuestro bebé
el 90% de las veces este tipo de
decisión se basa exclusivamente en la
estética
bueno ahora que los que sois padres
quieren marcharse y disculparse ante sus
hijos os doy una solución imaginaros que
tenemos dos tipos de pinturas la pintura
marca a la pintura marca ve las dos son
iguales lo único que cambia es el
fabricante vale entonces la pintura a
tiene un nivel de salud de 92 puntos y
la pintura ve tiene un nivel de salud de
52 puntos es decir la es más saludable
que la ve cuál vais a poner en la
habitación de vuestros hijos
bueno este tipo de información sobre
clasificación de materiales de
construcción no solo de pinturas pero de
todos los materiales que se pueden
aplicar en interiores la podéis
consultar de forma libre en frente y
materiales puntocom y ahora mismo yo
creo que muchos de vosotros os estaréis
preguntando pero i estany que me
interesa si no soy ni arquitecto ni
tengo ninguna relación con la industria
de la construcción bueno que sepáis que
según la epa que es la agencia ambiental
americana el grupo poblacional que se ve
más afectado por la contaminación en
ambientes interiores son los bebés y
niños pequeños las mujeres embarazadas o
en periodo de lactancia y la gente mayor
curiosamente este es el grupo
poblacional que suele pasar más tiempo
en interiores
y además todos hemos sido este bebé
muchas seremos madres y todos llegaremos
ancianos
por otra parte están reconocidos a nivel
científico a día de hoy problemas de
salud y patologías como la lipoatrofia
el síndrome del edificio enfermo o la
sqm que es una patología que tiene que
ver con la sensibilidad a agentes
químicos presentes en el interior la
intolerancia a redes wi-fi o a campos
electromagnéticos bueno yo nos hablo
sólo de salud habló también de
productividad hay un estudio que hizo
harvard en el año 2016 muy interesante
que es que lo que hace es la relación
entre un ámbito en un ambiente saludable
y la productividad la mejora en la
respuesta cognitiva es del orden del
casi 300 por ciento cuando uno trabaja
en un ambiente saludable
bueno y ahora ya para terminar y que veo
los hipocondríacos desmayados ahí al
final os doy unas cuantas
recomendaciones que creo que os pueden
resultar útiles para hacer con que
vuestras casas sean ambientes
verdaderamente saludables el primero de
todos económico y fácil de aplicar
ventilar vuestras casas regularmente
mínimo 15 minutos al día
otra recomendación la cerámica siempre
es una muy buena opción es un material
inerte es decir no desprende nada ni
absorbe nada es bastante económico muy
fácil de limpiar y además super
resistente
si tenéis que elegir una pintura elegid
pinturas con bajas emisiones de
compuestos orgánicos volátiles o
idealmente con emisiones cero este tipo
de información se encuentra en los
envases de pintura y no significa un
aumento de costes como comprar leche
desnatada o semidesnatada lo mismo sin
embargo si queréis ir al ferrario de las
pinturas podéis elegir una pintura
fotocatalítica que es una pintura que
tiene la capacidad de descontaminar el
aire cuando tiene contacto con la luz
natural es un proceso muy parecido a la
fotosíntesis
si tenéis que comprar muebles de madera
o estáis pensando cambiar vuestros
pavimentos nuestros suelos por un suelo
de madera un parquet certificados que se
tratan de mano de gas maderas perdón con
bajas emisiones de formaldehído es la
forma de garantizar que no estáis
contaminando el interior de vuestras
casas
otra recomendación muy importante las
prestaciones muchas veces son enemigas
de la salud
esto qué quiere decir
el mensaje es desconfiar siempre de un
material que tiene prestaciones que no
son las suyas originales como por
ejemplo una madera que no se quema o una
piedra que se dobla lo que se hace en
estos casos es impregnar a los
materiales con una sopa química que
confieren al material estas nuevas
prestaciones pero que al mismo tiempo
están contribuyendo a una contaminación
del aire interior
si no estáis en fase de reformar
nuestras casas o nuestras oficinas
ningún problema hay otro consejo
práctico que creo que es bastante útil
en el año 89 la nasa hizo un estudio en
el que identificaba las cinco plantas
más idóneas para contaminar el aire
anterior bueno entre ellas hay buenos
ejemplos aquí tenemos la espada de san
jorge' la palmera de bambú bueno y hay
otros para acabar el último ejemplo
bombillas ionizador as del aire os lo
explico el aire que respiramos está
cargado de iones entonces el aire del
campo os acordáis de esa primera foto
que os enseñé de la montaña pues el aire
de la montaña está cargado de iones
negativos que es lo que nos hace sentir
bien cuando respiramos por contra el
aire de la ciudad está cargado de iones
positivos entonces lo que hacen estas
bombillas es transformar los iones
positivos en iones negativos y no son
carísimas
y bueno para terminar me gustaría al
final todo esto que os he explicado no
es más que disponer del conocimiento
adecuado para hacer elecciones
responsables y me gustaría dejaros con
este último mensaje que es ahora que
podéis elegir salud y gracias
[Aplausos]